[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen endlich mal wieder zu einer
neuen mod vorstellung
ja die letzte vorstellung war ziemlich
ziemlich ziemlich lange her das war
einfach weil ich eine menge stress hatte
mit schule und alle möglichen deswegen
war es allgemein recht ärmlich an videos
aber diese mod vorstellung ist dafür
umso umfangreicher und zwar fügt diese
mod primitive mops hinzu also so heißt
der mord speziell die mod ich sag jetzt
die mod weil ich habe ganz viele leute
dazu bestimmt dass ich ja nicht mehr am
ort sagen soll also die mod ich denke
das wird relativ lange dauern
deswegen ich habe nichts vorbereitet
bisher ich habe mir nur so eine welt
geschaffen die ich sehr cool finde ich
mache das ganze nicht meiner mode
vorstellungswelt weil da wird alles
kaputt gehen und es sieht erstmal so aus
okay es gibt zehn neue mops aber das ist
ja auch nicht viel aber ich habe mir
zwei seiten notizen gemacht also das ist
eine ganz schöne menge und zwar gibt es
zwei freundlichem ob sie halten
doppelmords also doch soll das englisch
als freundlich behutsam und so weiter
und es gibt acht wütenden mobs also
hostile mops davon sind wir schon welche
irgendwie also das sind diese laufenden
travelling merchants und die wollte ich
auch als erstes vorstellen und zwar was
wollen wir einfach mal kann man diesem
fall niedrig die sehen aus wie ich
wartet so kümmert diesen ausweg nur das
den richtigen ecke dicken nase haben
naja was sind das überhaupt das sind so
umherlaufende will ja quasi mit einem
rucksack auf dem rücken
sehr cool die spawnen im flachland in
wüsten den flüssen in wäldern in extreme
hills zu jeder zeit also tag und nacht
findet ihr hier überall und die haben
ganz normal wie ganz normale villiger
auch unfaire handlungsmöglichkeiten dass
ich muss den drei mädels geben und er
gibt mir ein bücherregal das ist schon
sehr sehr asozial fenster auch ne kommt
jemand hier die von willibald fast
also die sind die benehmen sich wie
viele da wollte ich sage nur die spawn
fast überall und villagers bonn ja nur
in dörfern
also es ist ganz cool wenn man sich
diesem ort auf jeden fall installiert
weil dann hat man über all diese leute
die haben 20 gesundheit also ich kann
dir die ganze zeit drauf schlagen und
das steht schon relativ schnell und die
gruppen halt nix beim töten greift man
auch nicht an
und ja man kann ich noch keine erfahrung
also eigentlich relativ unnötig aus weil
das sind halt nur welcher die überall
herumlaufen sag ich mal
dann kommen sie zum zweiten und zwar dem
lost meiner den sehen wir hier der läuft
hier gerade so ein bisschen rum
ihr seht schon der verfolgt mich warum
verfolgt er mich ganz einfach die
verhalten sich auch wie normale will ja
nur dass sie vor zombies also die
verhalten sich nicht wie normale widget
das einzige was gleiches ist dass ihf
auch vor zombies angst haben und mit
denen hat man keine möglichkeiten zu
handeln als deswegen hab ich da grad
nach rechts kauf gemacht das war sehr
unklug dass gerade gemacht habe deswegen
richtigen hat mal ganz kurz um und zeigt
euch noch mal ein beispiel
und zwar findet man sie nur im
untergrund also in höhlen das heißt wenn
erhöhte seit kann sein dass der da auf
einmal auftritt
und wenn ihr dem näher kommt dann läuft
er einem die ganze zeit hinterher also
und der will von einem dass man ihn raus
aus dieser höhle bringt also der
verfolgt quasi allen apropos folgen
können über twitter folgen links in der
beschreibung oder her
nein und man hat quasi zwei
möglichkeiten wenn er eine auf ein
fokussiertes entweder man tötet ihn habe
ich ja grad gemacht
oder man macht rechtsklick auf ihn und
fit oder man geht halt aus der höhle
raus und wenn man dann draußen das kann
man recht auf ihn machen dann kommen da
so herz und er gibt einem null bis eins
bis sechs e mails dafür dass man ihn
daraus gebracht hat und zwar treten die
halt in höhlen auf und es kann auch sein
dass ich relativ weit oben auftrieb und
ganz rund und wenn ihr die halt raus
bringt dann freuen die sich und geben
euch entstehen dann einfach stumpf um
und dann kann man ja eigentlich auch
schon wieder töten weil dann bringt das
nichts mehr
die haben eine 20er gesundheit die aller
anderen will ich ja auch und die droppen
nix beim töten aber wenn ihr die
rausbringt richter hat ein paar e-mails
und das ist eigentlich ganz gut dann
kommen jetzt mal zu den haustüren ob sie
muss ich schon runter scrollen das ist
echt eine menge und zwar zum hort tool
das tue ich mir das ist nicht einfach
eine fixe oder ein schwert oder eine
schaufel oder einer axt die einfach so
auftritt und die attackieren jeden
spieler wenn man in der nähe ist ich
könnte mich jetzt in game auf null
setzen
allerdings war mein sporting wo der ganz
ganz weit hinten das heißt dass wir
relativ ungünstig ich zeige euch dass
man einfach alles im creative mode das
ist zufällig wie das auftritt und in
verschiedene materialien dass es in holz
auftritt passiert zu 35 prozent statt 30
prozent gold 20 prozent 10 prozent
diamant 5 prozent es macht ein schlag
von diesen dingen macht 505 herzen
schaden wenn ich keine rüstung und hätte
jetzt macht bei mir fast gar kein
schaden weil ich halt komplett die
rüstungen habe die gruppen sich selbst
beim töten das ist ja witzig als ich das
einmal schlagen so dann hab ich jetzt
hey das ist unfair komm her sportschule
jetzt kommen jetzt war los da so also
sieht nicht zu 100% robben die sich
immer selber aber wirklich meistens das
möchte ich jetzt gern zu machen aber
dann fand ich mensch werde dies bei
nacht überall und tags und nachts nur im
untergrund also immer im untergrund aber
bei nacht auch noch oben und das extra
ist dass die texte per kompatibel sind
das heißt wenn ich jetzt andere station
beck aussehen würde würden die genauso
aussehen wie die gegenstände die in dem
text ab excel aussehen so ich habe das
jetzt verstanden
naja ich werde wieder ein bisschen
schnell kommen wir nun zur mimik und
zwar das ist eine kiste hilfe
dies waren zu jeder zeit aber nur im
untergrund und design eigentlich aus wie
eine normale kiste nur da ist nicht
dieser komische rantrum und das hat auch
einen grund wenn man hat zwei
möglichkeiten wenn man rechtzeitig
darauf macht die erste möglichkeit ist
dass es sich in eine normale kiste
verwandelt mit zufälligen inhalt diese
chance dass das eintritt also eine
normale kiste ist allerdings nur ein
viertel oder jede vierte piste
verwandelt sich in eine normale kiste
bei 25 prozentige chance zweite
möglichkeit ist sie verwandeln sich in
einen gegner und greifen an so das ist
jetzt der fall das ist nicht meistens so
wenn ich jetzt ein game ort wäre wird
jetzt rumhüpfen und nicht auch angreifen
nur da ich jetzt im creative mode bin
also wenn ich im survival mode würde
nämlich angreifen aber da ich zur zeit
und relativ not been killed ich da
einfach nur wissen warum die hat
gesundheit 20 stärke 2 und die gruppen
beim töten sich selber also eine test
der sound auch ziemlich witzig so
erfahrung und die chest habe ich jetzt
also auch ganz witzig müsst ihr euch
jetzt nun immer franken
ist das jetzt der kiste soll ich die
alten richtig drauf machen oder nicht
naja kommen wir zum treasure schleim da
kann ich einfach mal so ein paar sporne
und sowas wollen noch einen darauf hin
dass ein ganz normales leben in
unterschiedlichen farben
unterschiedlichen größen und mit items
drinnen das ist der haupt hinzugefügte
mod weil ich muss mal wieder runter
scrollen weil der halt schon relativ
umfangreiches die legale weg geben mixa
bleibt doch die bewegen sich haben halt
auf die normale slams aber die haben ein
bestimmtes item in sich eingeschlossen
ist nicht einfach hier
denn ich hatte zum beispiel ein slime
eingeschlossen der da hatte ein
schneeball und eine herz eingeschlossen
zwar schnee bald hier ist ein schneeball
und die farbe bestimmt das tempo nicht
welches stück mit der fahrt über einen
also wenn ich jetzt jedes tonne
warum ist wartet das wollte ich noch
nicht der ist jetzt jedenfalls dass ein
herz drin das ist ein 3 anderes beispiel
soll wollte ich erst später zeigen
aber hier ist was drin also das stimmt
mit der farbe war ein du kommst mit ich
kann ich später einmal zeigen wahrheit
zu hüpfen jetzt täglich rum
beim töten droppen die dieses altem was
die in sich drin haben
jetzt wollen wir noch ein so da hat der
zoll in sich dringlich greift den an
er stirbt und gibt der red dot com
wieder raus und die dürfen alle diese
alters und haben eine ganze schleim
orgie
man bleibt stehen auch hilfe mein gott
wird wollte ich doch gar nicht bewirken
man verdammt
wieso muss ich euch natürlich
umfangreichen muss zeigen hilfe ja du
kommst erstmal mit hier ich zeige ich
später noch was der da beginnt sowie mit
sind jetzt erstmal alle umbringen über
alle nach diesem merger worum es geht
wenn ihr den bericht die mod runterladen
ihr habt eine heidenarbeit egal die
laufende von melexis ist relativ cool
hier liegt noch ein paar teams die
[Musik]
droppen halt dann dieses alters in denen
drin ist und die gesundheit und stärke
kommt auf die größe an also so einer ist
er zum beispiel stärker als so ein
kleiner da hinten die erst gegen ein
kaktus gelaufen wie das denn
und ja die spot zu jeder zeit im
untergrund und in allen regionen unter
der höhe
40 also unter y 40 wenn man f3 drückt
seht ihr hier ist y 64 also ein bisschen
weiter unten und die würden dann spawnen
das ist ganz einfach welche noch
flachland können die hier nicht bauen
weil ich halt über 40 bin deswegen habe
ich einfach so gespannt
und ich kann mich jetzt mal ganz kurz
ein paar beispiele geben zu welcher zeit
zu welcher wahrscheinlichkeit welches
altem kommt und zwar so ein herz hier
kommt zu 15 prozent also relativ häufig
und slime ball ganz einfach zu sechs
prozent ender perle 6% snowball zum
beispiel auch 6 prozent dann die unteren
stufe smart mark freeman cache diamond
waren jeweils 3% emerald golden apple
feiert unter 2% und musik ist und ein
sattel zu ein prozent was hat er da
bringt also nicht übrigens gibt es auch
noch das extra diese weise ins land die
haben ein herz in sich dass es der hier
und die gehorchen einem folgen allem
sätzlich auf den kopf wenn man mit denen
man richtig drauf macht also mache ich
jetzt einfach so kommen jetzt mit hier
so gut der sich bei mir auf den kopf
also dürfte bei nixon handhaben und
sieht das gefällt werden niedlich aus
sie ist tut mir jetzt leid aber so was
ich noch mal so tut mir leid aber naja
genervt ein bisschen warten jetzt einmal
kleinere raus nicht am tisch erst mal so
ich mache ich wieder die ganze schöne
map kaputt war
bald kommt der pc dann lag das auch
nicht mehr alles so wartet die ganzen
sachen die kann ja schon mal löschen
[Musik]
und dann kommen jetzt mal hier noch zu
den nächsten sachen also ändern wenn
sehr sehr eine sehr umfangreiche mod
daher warte kommt die löschen jetzt auch
schon mal hier behind the scenes und
soja
wenn er keine große produktions für mich
macht das eher alles selber im kanal
bestimmte wirklich hingesetzt auf die
ganzen sachen hier zusammen gesammelt
das könnte jetzt wieder runter so jetzt
muss ich mal runter scrollen
kommen wir zur spyder family die finde
ich besonders interessant und besonders
eklig und zwar kommt dort wenn man dies
pont eine mutter spinne mit null bis
sechs babys also es kommt nicht mal
babys aber höchstens sechs ich mal
wieder times hat null weil ich sehe dass
ist wenn wir nicht dunkel wird so haben
wir wieder morgen freut euch auch gerne
wandern gehen und diese babys bei dass
die kommen die wollen hat ihre mutter
beschützen und die mutter will ihre
babys bei das beschützen usw
gesundheit ist 30 und stärke 4 von der
mutter spyder und die truppen beim töten
string spenden auge oder einspinnen
so komme ich allerdings später mal und
die spawn weihnacht überall und sonst
nur im untergrund und in allen biom halt
ich zeige euch das erstmal hier habe ich
zb spinnens vailati ist jetzt noch
einmal hier gespannt keine ahnung ob man
das keineswegs dabei sind ihr seht schon
verdrängt ein sehr sehr schöner sound
wenn man die angreift und sport halt
drop teilt einspinnen auge oder halt
vielleicht mancher oder so kann ich euch
komme ich später wieder darauf zu
sprechen und eventuell kommen auch diese
babys bei dass dazu das seht ihr da
jetzt die laufen alle mit der mutter
herum
die greifen einen doch nicht an außer
man provoziert die ich bin dort eben
gamer deswegen reichlich egal keine 1
fällt mir ein dass jetzt immer auf den
kopf und so bleibt die bab 2 tonnen nur
mit der mutter spende an das kann man
die nicht bauern hört sich relativ
täglich an die folgen halt der mutter
und ja wenn man die wenn die mutter
spinne stirbt dann weinen die das sind
zur krailling partikels die dann
auftreten kann ja ganz gut zeigen so ich
will nur eure mutter hat wirklich so
guckt jetzt seht da da sind jetzt meine
sachen und die laufen jetzt verwirrt die
ganze zeit um einige laufen hinterher
andere laufende kaktus oder so die läuft
hinterher und für mich töten also die
laufen wirklich ziellos einfach nur rum
und sind alle total traurig lasse ich
mich in ruhe an wenn ich wieder
angreifen angreifen die mich halt auch
wieder an
wir versuchen zwar ich an gamer bin geht
das nicht und so bleibt gewisses die
haben allerdings nur die gesundheit 10
und stärker 1 und die broken strings
beim töten und online extra ist dass man
diese babys bei das zähmen kann und zwar
wenn eine mutter job der manchmal so
einspinnen auge kann ich euch jetzt
nicht zeigen dass es gar nicht geklappt
hat oder hat das geglaubten herzlich
allerdings wenn man so ein spinnen auge
hat ratet mal da ist es sogar noch cool
kann ich euch ganz gut zeigen könnt ihr
rechts machen dann habt ihr hier so eine
einen spinnen links und dann kommt da
wieder eine zerbrochene scheibe raus 1
beier action und wartet dass man ganz
ganz das inventar lief folge und ist mit
dem ganzen paket so und die sehen mich
jetzt als ihre mutter an und folgen
metern die ganze zeit greifen muss
sondern ich die töte und so die haben
wir zwar die aktien allerdings würde ich
dir nicht haben deswegen tödlich die so
ich möchte dazu hier so destroy schön
also das sind die baby spiders und ja
die sehe ich dann halt als mutter an
wenn ich die
zehn tipps oder kommt zur locke prima
wenn ich da hin setze passiert erstmal
nichts gleich im gameplay welche
allerdings angreife springt er nach oben
springt nach unten wie eine bombe und
explodiert dann hier einfach also wenn
ich das hier mache und dann explodierte
er halte hier so sehr sehr cool
naja die explodieren hat nicht die
normale grippe sondern machen halt auf
unserem hohen bogen und dann runter in
höhlen ist das sehr witzig und zwar in
höhlen dass die deckenhöhe ja meistens
so drei bis zu zehn blöcke da springt
dann hoch und können dann direkt wieder
runter und naja da sollte man am besten
einfach weglaufen
die gesundheit von diesen krieg bis 15
sie sind schneller als normale grippe
und die droppen tnt beim töten
allerdings nicht zu 100 prozent die
beiden jetzt gar nichts geklappt weil
ich die ja doch nicht getötet hat
versucht jetzt mal zu töten
ja ja ja es hat relativ schwer die zu
töten droppen dann tnt wenn das wenn sie
getötet werden
das gibt's sonst auszudehnen zu sagen
die sind selten als normale grippe also
tue
zum glück is born weihnacht überall und
sonst immer im untergrund in allen biom
und einen extra ist die glocken eine
andere schallplatte als normale grippe
beim tod durch einen service der auch im
normalen an drobny schallplatte die
dropmann eine unterschiedliche rekord
schallplatte er kommt zu anderen kriegt
man und zwar den festbetrieb an
da möchte ich jetzt noch keinen sport
bzw ich bin im braker greift nämlich
ähnlich an und zwar wenn ihr dachtet
dass die roccat creeper schlimm sind
dann müsst ihr euch das jetzt mal
anhören und zwar schmeißt die
themenblöcke nach einem und diese sind
auch bereits gezündet dann die haben die
gesundheit von 25 gruppen feuerzeuge
aber noch nicht zu 100 prozent der sowie
trocknet creeper tnt drop in drop
feuerzeug allerdings nicht immer die
sind viel seltener als normale grippe
und die sporen weihnacht überall und
sonst immer im untergrund in allen bio
und die haben halt auch die zwei extras
oder eine extra dass sie auch noch
andere schallplatte droppen beim tod
durch ein skelett pfeil und das andere
sache die andere sache ist die schmeißen
kein tnt nach ein wenn man in einem haus
ist also ich kann ich das mal ganz gut
ich kann der boden brennt dann so ein
bisschen die sind übrigens immun gegen
feuer
so kam jetzt weiß man hier was so
ach mist ich bin im game ich vergesse
immer wieder so wirst du schon steht
also schon auch wieder gemacht wir die
ganze map kaputt hier so wenn ich dann
eher an den rand und ein bisschen zäh
und biss einem schlag dazu ist die kein
tnt allerdings beim tod lasst es auch
nochmal an tnt fallen und so weiter ich
gehe mal wieder gegen heute bevor ich
hier noch irgendwie sterbe mit den
ganzen mops hier also das sind die vest
equity partners fest des kriegers das
sind so die stärksten mops themen
kompletten spiel beziehungsweise die wir
euch am meisten schaden bereiten werden
dann kommen wir zum brains leiden kann
ich einfach mal hinsetzen das sind
kleine die gibt es auch in größeren
größen hier wie zum beispiel die die
töte ich mal ganz kurz und ich möchte
ich auch nicht sehen weg hier so ich
beschäftige mich jetzt erstmal nur mit
dem also grenzland die setzen sich auf
dem kopf des spielers wenn man ja zu
ihnen kommt ich bin im gamer deswegen
tun dass gerade nicht ich werde euch
gleich allerdings noch mal demonstrieren
glaube ich die versuchen an das gehirn
auszusaugen wie zombies und dann muss
dann so nach oben schon um sie zu töten
wie bei diesem treffer slime da ist auch
noch in treasuries zu sein kann ich
immerhin noch töten weg sondern hier
ach da drin ist die anti baby spiders
die so rum geheult haben auch das ist
sehr traurig das tut mir leid jetzt wir
können übrigens nachher noch mal hier
rein gucken was so im tempel alles drin
das war ich bin genau hier gespannt wenn
ich bin da hinten bis vorne hingeflogen
dann kommt man da gleich mal reingucken
ja die versuchen halt das gehirn aus zu
sorgen und die kommen halt in
unterschiedlichen größen vor und zwar
machen die großen slams natürlich mehr
schaden als die kleinen und die
gesundheit und stärke kommt wie bei den
thrashers 2 muss halt auch auf die größe
an also kleinere slams bleiben wir
natürlich halten weniger aus als die
großen die gruppen schleimbeutel hat
schon gesehen und dies konnte jedoch
zeit am strand also nicht wirklich stand
sondern diese kleinen sandflächen da
mehr einen ozean flüssen auf sand und
gräser blätter hat sich manchmal ganz
kurz in game holt 0
er setzt auf mir drauf und macht mir ein
bisschen schaden allerdings hält schon
relativ wenig weil ich halt eine rüstung
auf habe ich ihnen etwas runter schlagen
die kommen auch wieder auf mich drauf so
jeder will mal auf meinen kopf kommen
wer will noch mal wer hat noch nicht
sonst noch vielleicht irgendwie keiner
mehr war nicht okay na gut also dass
fahren diese brain slams teile finde ich
eigentlich auch ganz witzig pink sei es
genau ist aber dann kommen jetzt zum
letzten mob alltag wünschen bei fast 20
minuten ist wieder krass wie ich mich
immer vorbereitet
daumen hoch dafür nein spaß nein support
creeper wenn die alleine sind verhalten
sich wie normale grippe aber auch nur
dann wenn man die wände mit einem
anderen monster in die nähe kommen dann
bringen sie diesen mob ein stärker ein
feuer resistance und ein speed und wenn
dieser verstärktem ob dann stirbt geben
die die attribute einem anderen namen
mob und wenn keiner halt in der nähe ist
dann geben sie das hat auch keinem
anderen ich kann ich das einfach mal ein
beispiel von einem zombie zeigen
ach so die haben gesundheit 30 die
krippenfeier chart ist aber auch nicht
zu 100 prozent also so wie die anderen
auch nicht zu 100 prozent glaubt nicht
dass die sportnacht überall und sonst
halt immer im untergrund in allen blumen
und das extra ist dass die auch noch
andere schallplatte droppen als die
dings so warte ich mach das jetzt mal
ganz kurz so schlag gehen jetzt der hat
jetzt feuer résistance und an der brend
gerade warte ich habe auf jeden fall das
maßlos wenn ich mit denen in der nähe
bin ich gehe mal ganz kurz ein game zu
null so die kommt zu mir hin und zwar
der zombie hat jetzt die fähigkeiten das
der stärker ist und alles mögliche und
wenn ich jetzt dafür einsetze so dann
kriegt er wieder ein paar sachen guckt
er wird schon der not so komisch und hat
all die ganzen eigenschaften wie dieser
krippe und ihr seht auch reagiert ja
normaler krieg also das war es auf jeden
fall erstmal mit dieser modifikation mit
dieser mod dieser mod ich habe ihr
versprochen dass wir am ende auf jeden
fall mal hier rein gehen werden
ich würde euch auf jeden fall sagen
würdet euch die mod weil die ist auf
jeden fall sehr sehr geil innovativ und
endet nicht nur ein mord sondern ist
schon so ein bisschen umfangreich und
ich habe mich ja gerade so circa eine
stunde darauf vorbereitet ich würde mich
echt kacke drin so was ist denn das
hilft ja das würde aber wo mein gott
walther diesen ort bekloppt die teile
[Musik]
[ __ ] euch die armen schön diamanten die
extra reingelegt hat man ich dachte
jetzt schreiben sie kommentare hey wie
heißt der fita wenn er ganz viele
diamanten einen natürlich weil ich ja
schon vorher drin ob die einfach da rein
gelegt ich wollte eigentlich kommen mit
diamanten schreiben aber wir gehen das
nicht weil das zu klein war der platz
nach oben im fleisch na ja ich würde
mich auf jeden fall freuen schaffen wir
eventuell 1500 like seite übrigens immer
noch da wenn immer noch da seid schreib
doch mal alle kräfte in die kommentare
einfach kontrast dar ein schreiben wenn
ihr noch immer da seid ihr könnt auch so
oft kommen kontrakt reinschreiben wir
wollten mir egal
einfach damit wir so ein bisschen
aktivität hier haben in den kommentaren
schreib doch mal rein wir die
modifikation findet und halt ja schaffen
wir 1500 likes dass wir auf jeden fall
richtig haben ich habe mich sehr sehr
lange darauf vorbereitet möglich solche
motto ich mich lange darauf vorbereitet
oder soll ich lieber mehr machen und
dafür dann nicht so lange drauf
vorbereiten aber schreibt das einfach
als in die kommentare
wie geht's euch das macht er heute noch
feilt er auch karneval und ja ich habe
euch alle ganz doll lieb
[Musik]